today on the matt wells show joe biden
was already having the worst
presidential term in american history
and that was before russia invaded
ukraine bringing us closer to world war
iii and it's not a coincidence that this
has happened after biden spent his first
year in office focusing primarily on
wokeness and intentionally making our
military weaker and more feminine so
we'll talk about that today also canada
proposes legislation that will allow
people to report hate speech before it
happens
so brave new world meets the minority
report in canada plus a trucker convoy
heads to dc i have my reservations about
this one and i'll explain also a writer
for new york magazine says that parents
who insist on parental rights are
actually household tyrants and finally
in our daily cancellation we'll look at
the fat acceptance activist who says
that dieting is a form of conversion
therapy yes all of that and more today
on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as inflation continues it's important to
keep your budget and financial goals top
of mind think about the things that you
can do today to come out ahead like
refinancing your mortgage if it's not on
your to-do list it should be because you
could be paying a lot less for your home
right now and i know just the people to
help american financing a family-owned
mortgage lender that's known for its
custom home loans and it's no pressure
approach to lending from lower rates to
shorter terms and even debt
consolidation they do whatever it takes
to set you up for financial success they
could help you save up to a thousand
dollars a month plus tens of thousands
long term so why not learn more if you
start soon you may get to skip two
payments and could close in as little as
10 days on top of that so you're saving
a lot of money in the long run you're
also saving money which is great in the
short term
because you get to skip a couple of
those payments as well there is no
downside to at least giving them a call
which you can do at 866-569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 give them a call today or
visit americanfinancing.net
america financing nmls 18234
well uh on second thought maybe it
wasn't such a good idea to make a
dementia patient president wasn't a good
idea in first thought either but you
know here we are with russia's invasion
of ukraine and the war drums beating
louder than ever in the west potentially
inching us closer to a third world war
we can definitively say though we could
have said it before this point
that no president in american history
has done this much damage this quickly
now we live in an age of hyperbole when
every bad thing is the worst thing ever
and every bad person is literally hitler
and every politician we don't like is
the worst politician ever and also
literally hitler one of the consequences
of all this exaggeration is that we have
no way to sufficiently describe people
and things that really are historically
bad
and in this case it actually is true
that joe biden is so far the worst
president in american history and the
competition isn't very close i mean the
gap between second and third worst is
much smaller than the gap between second
worst and joe biden worst of all he has
been disaster on every front in every
way
from every conceivable angle
and the worst thing about him being the
worst
is that it was all totally foreseeable
we knew that he's an elderly man losing
control of his mental faculties we knew
that his handlers are far left
ideologues and slimy soulless grifters
and con artists
we knew that his administration would
put wokeness before all else
he's done mostly what he said he would
do even if he doesn't remember saying it
and it's as bad as we knew it would be
or should have known
today some of those things loom
especially large like the fact that for
example joe biden shut down the keystone
pipeline and destroyed any hope of
american energy independence
in fact the whole western world
abandoned that goal over the last couple
of years largely because an annoying
little swedish girl yelled at us about
it
so we said okay well never mind forget
about energy
now we import 20 million barrels of oil
from russia every month
with no plan in place to replace that
production once the spigot is turned off
biden made sure that we were dependent
upon our adversaries for survival while
also making sure that our adversaries
won't respect or fear us
a lethal combination as we're seeing
this morning i've been thinking a lot
about one of biden's very first acts
while in office one of the very first
things he did
you know he shut down keystone
but even before that
one of the first things he did was to
invite a flamboyant social media
influencer to the white house to film a
tick-tock skit
let's go back and relive that one
together
one sec democracy's calling see you
daddy bye hi my name is cooper and this
is a day in my life as a white house
intern
[Music]
we did a joke
hey everyone
usually i start off with a big coffee
sorry they're like really strict in here
hey jenny i booked you a nail
appointment love yeah i didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative
hi white house is a scooper um i don't
think so
oh it doesn't matter
this is actually the entrance to the
west wing this is so fun and it's really
prestigious hey potus is olivia
rodriguez still here no
we've come a long way in our fight
against this virus we've vaccinated 160
million americans are you getting this
all down don't worry queen it's all
right here
cooper sorry miss jen and jen don't
forget to have fun
spirit fingers mama we need to get shots
in the arms of every single american i'm
heading to a haircut comment if you want
me to make more of these
russia and china are not exactly quaking
in their boots when they see that except
from hysterical laughter
not the kind of laughter you want
worse this administration has wokefied
our national defense apparatus and
bragged about doing it
i mean who can forget the cia ads trying
to entice new recruits by promising gay
acceptance and rainbow flags
or what about the army recruitment ad
that looked like an actual disney
princess movie
complete with uh singing and all of that
or the recruitment ad again aimed at
women but featuring a female gay rights
activist with two moms let's go back
today and watch that one again
although i had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet
played violin
i also marched for equality
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
when i was six years old one of my moms
had an accident that left her paralyzed
doctors said she might never walk again
but she tapped into my family's pride to
get back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
and then attended uc davis where i
joined a sorority full of other strong
women
but as graduation approached i began
feeling like i'd been handed so much in
life
a sorority girl stereotype
sure i'd spent my life around inspiring
women
but what had i really achieved on my own
one of my sorority sisters was studying
abroad in italy another was climbing
mount everest
i needed my own adventures
my own challenge
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
you notice there of course that the army
is presented uh not as something that
you join to defend your country and kill
bad guys but as a an opportunity for
self-discovery
you know
just like along the lines of a sorority
girl
studying abroad in italy or climbing
mount everest
i mean how could putin
do what he's doing right now
doesn't he know that western countries
have the most diverse equitable tolerant
and trans-inclusive militaries in the
history of the world
and he's still messing with us
wow
i mean it's almost like we're nothing
but a joke at this point
just this month a couple of weeks just a
couple weeks ago actually this month the
defense department official website
ran this article this again was this
month
um
diversity equity inclusion are
necessities in the us military that's
the headline and it says in part
diversity equity inclusion in the
military are necessities for the united
states
bishop garrison the senior adviser to
the secretary of defense for human
capital and diversity equity inclusion
said
garrison spoke to the center for a new
american security today about the
progress being made by the department
and what still needs to happen
some 41 of the military identify as
members of minority groups and that that
number will grow larger garrison said
the military must be able to attract
train and retain them
for the services to retain competitive
edges he said garrison said the need for
diversity equity and inclusion to be
consideration or a part of all decisions
in the military
diversity and equity inclusion have to
be a part of all decisions in the
military
there is a direct line connecting this
kind of madness with what we're
witnessing overseas right now
we advertised weakness
we bragged about it
we announced to the world repeatedly
that we are now a theocratic state
but our religion is wokeness
and it's less a religion than a death
cult a suicide pact
we give up our own energy production for
its sake
we weaken our defenses for it
we will take institutions that were once
killing machines and repurpose them to
prioritize equity and inclusion
did we think that putin wouldn't notice
that
now blame putin for invading ukraine
sure he's the one doing it
but once you're done pointing that
finger and you feel a little better
get it out of your system
i think it's time to conduct a much more
painful and necessary investigation of
ourselves and our country and our
government
because war and conquest have been the
way of the world since the dawn of man
that will always be the case
if you thought you were living in a day
and age where that's behind us and it
doesn't happen anymore
then you're a fool
you're just like the people who you know
were shocked when a pandemic hit it's oh
i didn't know this kind of thing still
happens of course it happens
it's always going to happen there are
diseases in the world sometimes there
will be one particular disease that lots
of people get at the same time
so we've had two things in the last few
years
that we were shocked by even though
there's no excuse to be shocked
because these things happening it just
puts us right in line with everybody
else who's ever lived on earth
now it doesn't make it good or right
certainly doesn't make it fun or
enjoyable it just makes it what what is
it makes it reality
we can choose to operate within reality
or without
you know on the outside of it
biden and the left choose to be outside
of reality
in a place where there is no more war
and nobody wants to conquer anything and
everybody gets along and so we can set
out to fill our military with lesbians
who can't do three push-ups
why not this is also the world where
climate change is the greatest threat we
face so we can shut down our oil
pipelines pipelines because a 15 year
old environmentalist made us feel bad
and no negative consequences will come
of it we think
that's the world the left wants to
pretend we live in
until the real world comes crashing
through the barrier
the sort of wall of delusion they've
erected around themselves and when that
happens
what do they do
they start pointing the blame everywhere
and at everything and everybody but
themselves
and they also as they've been doing
especially over the past couple days
call for us to unite and come together
so just today uh senator brian schatz
who has a last name that i'll never not
find funny uh tweeted this he says it is
more essential than ever that we rally
around our president as he leads the
free world in response
if your instinct is to try to turn this
into a partisan political advantage or a
viral tweet
step off the stage
rally around joe biden
that can't happen because though we've
listed lots of the bad things biden has
done we haven't mentioned the worst one
of all
he has intentionally cast his own people
as the enemy
he has set his sights on chasing down
and punishing right-wingers and those
who disagree with him he's labeled
parents at school board meetings
domestic terrorists
and now the domestic terrorists are
supposed to rally around him
we're the enemy
right that's what he said we're scum
we're the greatest threat to the safety
of this country and yet now he needs our
support
now that he needs us we're americans but
when he doesn't need us anymore we go
back to being being rabid dogs that have
to be caged or put down
you know the left is a lot like a
drunken abusive husband who sobers up
for three hours and expects affection
and cheerfulness from his wife
hey honey i haven't i haven't beat you
in three three hours what's the big deal
now we say of women who go along with
that that uh they have battered wife
syndrome
what the left wants from us now is a
sort of political battered wife
but that's not how this works
you said that we're the enemy you hate
us we're nazis and terrorists
you shouldn't want our help or support
and anyway you won't have it
biden made this bed
and now he'll have to lay in it
on his own
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know you might not realize this but
85 percent of the grass-fed beef in the
united states is imported from overseas
so this is a problem that we're seeing
quite a lot um now as we're bringing
things in from the overseas rather than
producing them here here's the catch
these foreign products are often labeled
product of usa since they're minimally
processed here even though they're not
really made here so don't pay a premium
for low quality foreign meat good
rancher sells 100 american meat and they
deliver it to your door for a great
price they only sell 100 american meat
sourced from local american farms their
beef is prime and upper choice the
highest quality possible they've got rib
eyes t-bones new york strips and more
i've had them all and they're all
delicious plus their packaging makes it
easy to cook
what you want and save the rest which
keeps you from wasting anything as well
so head on over to goodranchers.com
walsh today to solve your meat problem
once and for all get the transparency
the quality the cuts that you've been
craving order now with code walsh to get
30 off your box now now's the time to
support american farms and ranches
they're hurting and you're hungry so you
could kill two birds with one stone here
and uh get a box of american meat
delivered whoever buys the meat in your
house needs to go to goodranchers.com
walsh today
so uh last night you can imagine how fun
this was for me we had a uh dog trainer
come to the house to help us figure out
why the dog hates me and barks at me all
the time
um
because it's always a mystery why how
could anybody hate me and uh but
especially the dog why is the dog such
an ungrateful brat that he eats my food
uh lives under my roof
while barking and growling at me like
any other entitled member of generation
z
that was the question so we had the
trainer come she was great she was uh
very competent very friendly very
professional very good at what she was
doing
knew what she was doing but but it was
it was like an hour and a half and
mostly we were talking to her you know
the whole time because she was trying to
to you know find out about the dog and
figure all this stuff out and so it's
like this long interview process about
the dog and it's the longest i've ever
spent
talking about a dog in my entire life
and most of the conversation consisted
of us describing the dog's behavior
and then uh and then and then giving our
interpretation of that behavior and then
her politely explaining that we're
totally wrong in our interpretation so
like for example
my wife does this thing where she that
she likes uh that she thinks is very
cute where she'll start singing
and then the dog will run into the room
and kind of like jump up on her
as she's singing and she she has
interpreted this as the dog wants to
dance with her
and i was always skeptical of that
interpretation i didn't have the heart
to say anything so she told this to the
trainer and the trainer had no
compunction about it she said i don't
know that's
you know he probably just doesn't like
it when you're singing he's trying to
tell you to stop
so anyway what we learned
after the dog whisperer conducted her
pet psychic seance
is that the dog lacks confidence and he
has a self-esteem issue
and um and can you imagine again just
imagine me sitting there for an hour and
a half listening to this about a dog
self-esteem issues
and we have to build up his self-esteem
and of course i'm sitting there thinking
like why is that my problem
why can't the dog just suck it up what
does he want from me oh you have a
self-esteem
problem dog you join the club we all do
you don't see me barking at people
because of it
i guess i sort of do in my own way but
still
um but here's the upshot good news
according to the trainer
um
because the dog lacks confidence around
me especially and is getting adjusted to
us and he's getting settled in what that
means is that for the foreseeable future
i've been instructed to ignore the dog
like don't pet him don't don't don't be
the one feeding him don't take him out
for any walks don't take him out at
night like i had been doing so don't do
any chores related to the dog that's
what she said
that is what she said
i have to give the dog space that's my
instruction
and so as hard as it will be for me to
do
nothing at all that's what i'll do
i know i have to do nothing and have my
wife do everything as far as the dog is
concerned
it's what she recommends you know it's
not what i want it's what she said and i
for one think we need to take her
recommendations very seriously
and i kind of explained to my wife after
the trainer left
i said you know i think this woman knows
what she's talking about um
she really seemed to have it together
she said i shouldn't do anything and i
you know it pains me because of how much
i love the dog and i want to bond with
the dog and i want to help you but i
just i can't i have to do nothing
and i also explain that you know
i probably should
again just because i'm concerned about
the dog i mean things like
she wanted me to take the trash out
after the trainer left and i said i
probably shouldn't do that because that
means that i'm leaving and coming back
in it always upsets the dog when i walk
in the door and it hurts his confidence
his self-esteem i don't want to do that
you know putting the kids down for bed
at night i probably should just not i
probably should just sit on the couch
and watch tv i probably shouldn't be
doing that i'm moving around too much
so
you know it's it's all about the dog and
i am here to help the dog by doing
nothing for him at all
okay let's uh
start
here
from the post-millennial
by the way one other point about that i
i have
mentioned these dog problems on the show
a few times and i've gotten a lot of
advice
in the comments section
and you know i'm not saying who's
writing who's wrong but i will tell you
i didn't say where i got i didn't tell
the trainer that i got that prior to
this i'd been doing things that i
learned from youtube comments
but the trainer did say i don't mean to
throw you guys under the bus but she she
did say that all of that advice was
terrible so
and i agree because most of the other
advice involved me doing things so
that's when the post-millennial says
proposed hate-speech legislation in
canada would allow people to take others
to court if they suspect that someone
will post content deemed hateful online
will post
bill c-36 states that a person may with
the attorney general's consent
lay an information before a provincial
court judge if the person fears on
reasonable grounds that another person
will commit an offense under section 318
or subsection 3319
which is about inciting or promoting
hate or promoting hatred
it also covers quote an offense
motivated by bias prejudice or hate
based on race national or ethnic origin
language color religion sex age mental
or physical disability
sexual orientation gender identity or
expression or any other similar factor
so those are the reasons that you're
you're not allowed to hate someone for
any of those reasons
but you you can still hate them and you
can even say that you hate them it's
just there are specific reasons why
you're not so there there's a category
of reasons that are not acceptable for
hating somebody and then there's a
category that still is acceptable so you
can
um hate
someone just because of who they are
and this is something i've never quite
understood
like if i'm going to be hated by another
person and
you might argue that perhaps there are a
few people a few people out there who do
hate me
and if i could choose
between being hated because of my skin
color or my gender or something or being
hated because of just who i am at a deep
and personal level
i think i would i would prefer the skin
color and gender-based hatred because it
doesn't go as deep
right
so if anything that that would that to
me that's not his insult not nearly as
insulting
because then i'm just getting lumped in
with everybody else who shares this
feature it's not my fault that i have
this characteristic and so if you hate
me for that reason that's kind of like
your problem
but if you say no i i it's not because
that i just hate who you are i hate
everything about you down to your soul
that's what it is
that to me is that's gonna hurt a little
bit more
so i've never quite understood why
that's the kind of hatred that's the
kind of bigotry that's acceptable
you can say oh i really hate you oh do
you hate me because of my is it because
of my skin color no is it because of my
gender no
oh it's fine then
that i don't get
uh going back to the article says
diversity minister ahmed hussein
reintroduced the legislation after
events that transpired in ottawa in
which a very small number of individuals
at the freedom convoy
protest allegedly carried hateful
symbols including swastikas
ahmed called the symbols reprehensible
and said that the government would
reintroduce the bill that died when the
election was called last year he said
seeing symbols of hate right across the
doorstep of our parliament parliament is
unbelievable and should be condemned
now
this does raise another question well
many questions are raised like
another one is and it actually is not
explained
how could you report this stuff
before it happens
i mean it's bad enough to have hate
speech laws on the books how are you
reporting it before it happens is this
minority report do you have uh psychics
that you that you have hooked up to
tubes in
some kind of weird petroleum jelly that
was am i thinking of the right movie
yeah that's that movie which never made
a lot of sense to me by the way because
it's like set in the future and they
have this
technology you'd think they have
technology to read the future or to know
what's going to happen in the future but
instead they have these psychics that
they've
they don't really explain that but
anyway
is that is that how you're finding out
that someone's going to
post hate speech in the future that
really isn't explained
and the other question is well how do
you
how do you define hate
how do you determine it
because hatred is a motivation that is
based within a person's heart right it's
it's deep within them so how could you
possibly know whether someone is hateful
or not well it does say this it doesn't
provide a clear-cut definition of what
hate is but instead says that quote
hatred means the emotion that involves
detestation or vilification and that is
stronger than dislike or disdain
oh i mean
silly me i thought disdain and hatred
were kind of
you know
synonyms
loathing someone disdaining them hating
them i kind of thought that's sort of
the same thing
but now it's it's one step above disdain
or dislike or even strong dislike
so does that mean that according to the
law you can strongly dislike someone for
their sexual orientation gender or race
you just can't hate them
does that become a valid defense in the
court of law when you're bringing in a
you know a perpetrator of alleged hate
speech
can he defend himself by saying no i
don't i don't hate this person because
of the race i just strongly dislike it
this is the total absurdity that you
immediately descend into
when you try to have laws against hate
of any kind for any reason
there's no way to know
what's going on inside someone's heart
and and also
there's there's no reason why
hatred should be considered the worst
thing i mean
so we take um what about a hate crime
you know canada has more hate speech
laws than we have but we both have this
category of hate crime and if you commit
a hate crime then that's a that's an act
that's a federal charge and now that's
going to be a worse sentence that you
get
um
now the things that are done if you kill
someone
and it's allegedly a hate crime well
obviously the the murder if you're
murdering an innocent person you should
go to jail for that
but we've decided quite arbitrarily
that the worst reason to kill somebody
is because you hate them
and so there should be
sometimes a quite significant extra
sentence it's a whole extra crime that
you get charged for if you murder them
for hate
but why is that the case because for one
thing if you kill someone they're just
as dead no matter the reason for it
um
but also
probably the majority of murders
the murders that that happen you know
between strangers majority of murders
and and kind of violence happen in
domestic disputes and that sort of thing
but um
if we're talking about
a stranger murdering somebody else
you know many of those murders
are are not grounded in hate they're
grounded in just
basic indifference to human life
so if you read of a case in the city
where someone
gets shot in the head uh
for the five dollars in their wallet
well that's that's not a hate crime
because the reason that they were killed
was for the five dollars not because of
the person's race
and so our emphasis on hate crimes and
our system of law will say that well
that's
that's bad
but it's not as bad as it could have
been
i would say it's it's at least as bad
you know killing someone because you
want to take five dollars from them and
killing them because you don't like the
way they look
i would put them at least on part
and if anything
uh
the former is is maybe even worse
murder out of pure indifference
i don't even care about you enough to
hate you
i'm gonna kill you for the five dollars
because your life just means nothing to
me
i i don't even i don't have the energy
to hate you
that's a step up from how i feel about
you you are you are just nothing to me
you're dirt
so many murders especially in the the
inner cities are are motivated by that
total indifference to human life
so why should we have a special category
for that
make that its own federal charge it just
becomes absurd
um
but again it also requires in order to
parse all these things well was it uh
total indifference to human life was it
hatred was it disliked was it disdain
it requires you to peer inside
somebody's soul
and make these determinations which you
just can't do
all right this is from usa today it says
as many as 700 national guard members
are prepared to take posts across the
nation's capital amid planned trucker
protest convoys that organizers say
could paralyze the city without entering
it
um bob bolus a pennsylvania truck driver
says he's leading the free freedom
convoy of trucks from pennsylvania to
washington on wednesday
but he told nbc 4tv in washington that
he has backed off immediate plans to
gridlock the capital beltway um
and
uh he says for right now they're not
shutting the traffic down but he says
quote if we don't have a resolution from
the government to the rights that
they're taking from us i would predict
in the future it will get shut down
so the convoy is is headed to uh dc and
it's they want to arrive right in time
basically for the state of the union
and
that's an interview with one of the
organizers but we have here a clip this
is uh someone else who also identifies
themselves as one of the leaders and
organizers of the um
of this trucker convoy that's coming to
dc
and here he's explaining you know what
it is and i guess because one question i
have when i when i first heard about a
trucker convoy being organized in the
united states to go to dc it was like
okay what
what are they trying to accomplish we
know about the truckers in canada and
why that convoy happened and what what
their demands were right what they were
rallying for
but why the trucker protest here well
let's listen to what this guy says maybe
he'll explain it
this message is for the president of the
united states of america
my name is kyle sepchik of the freedom
convoy usa 2022 and our routes meet here
in d.c on march 1st and time for your
state of the union address we are very
organized and our routes our public i
even pulled a permit for the national
mall to be respectful i just want to be
as transparent as possible from the
start so there's no confusion we are
coming peacefully and we're going to do
this lawfully and constitutionally i
want the rest of the world to know our
plans so that there's no twisting and
lying about who and what we are
i'm coming to you as a father a small
business owner who's unaffiliated to any
parties we just want government
overreach to end
on behalf of freedom convoy usa 2022 we
are asking you to end the state of
emergency and the mandates once and for
all
sir the world is watching us because
they know that if what's happening in
canada happens to us here in the land of
the free then freedom as we know it is
gone
yeah i gotta i gotta be totally honest
with you and i might be going out on a
limb here i'm not sure how many of you
will follow me on it um
i i really don't
i don't love this idea of this trucker
convoy
it makes me
uneasy
um especially now
right i mean biden is
and and the democrats in general
are tanking in the polls they're only to
go lower from here
you know this is this is a game of limbo
now how low can you go and they're going
to go very very low
um
that's kind of from a from a political
standpoint and a protest is a is a
political it's a it's a political
statement
and so there should be some political
calculation that goes into any kind of
protest that's how you should be
thinking about it if you're not thinking
of it in those terms and you shouldn't
be doing it
and so
what exactly is the trucker protest
going to potentially accomplish
other than turning the attention to you
in a potentially very negative way
depending on how it goes
and what happens
i mean all it would seem to potentially
accomplish is just distracting
from
uh you know from from biden what a
terrible job he's doing
as far as mandates go well okay this is
a trucker convoy to end the mandates but
so if you're doing it a year ago then i
understand but but what federal mandates
are you even protesting now
the vast majority of the mandates are
gone
so what what federal man mandates
exactly are they protesting because they
should be very specific
that's the other thing you need to be in
a protest is specific
about what exactly you're protesting and
and what you would like to see happen
so you have to you have to have an idea
in mind of what victory looks like what
does it look like to win here
and i think very often there are
protests and demonstrations where
people don't think about that ahead of
time they don't think about what does a
wind look like to me
and so they just go and kind of do
something and let the chips fall where
they may but
uh that that as we have seen is is
often not the best strategy
so most of the man federal mandates are
gone or have been defeated in court
um there's still the vaccine mandate for
healthcare workers which is a very bad
thing i mean is that what this is
specifically about
um and there's the federal mandate for
public transportation you have to wear
masks on planes which is also stupid
so is that is that it
but again it does it still raises the
question of why
why now why not a year ago
we've already seen so we saw the trucker
convoy it already happened this feels
like a rehash of something that just
happened
um when there's
but but with clear with less clear goals
in mind
and then you're going to dc and it's
well we're not shutting down traffic but
we might
maybe we'll create a massive gridlock
and
we we don't all even agree on like why
we're doing this i'm telling you that is
a disaster that is a disaster
to go in to dc
around the state of the union
and potentially maybe i mean there's
again it's
it doesn't seem everyone doesn't seem to
be on the same page but potentially
create massive gridlock and a huge
inconvenience for everybody in city
without being able to
in a unified way even explain why you're
doing it
or what you want to see happen
that is a recipe to turn all the
backlash against you
distracting from joe biden and what a
terrible job he's doing
i mean i i don't think when i when i
think of the
how democrats in congress and the
administration
how they're looking at this i doubt that
they're sitting there
you know
uh
biting their fingernails nervous and
saying oh i i hope
i wish they weren't coming i think
they're probably pretty happy about this
that you're going to come and create a
big distraction and make it about you it
sounds good to us
gets the heat off us for a little bit
and always with the potential for things
to go very very bad
i mean we don't have to
probably don't have to remind you of
january 6th
that was another
massive demonstration where it was never
exactly clear what the end goal was
and the next thing you know you had
people going into the capital and
certainly there was no idea they had no
idea why they were doing it or or what
what victory was supposed to look like
here they just were kind of like doing
something
and i look at this and i think that
makes me uneasy for that reason
also the potential you have to think
about these things
for people to infiltrate this and
you know
uh
kind of try to turn it against you from
the inside
the way the ways the the
the people can kind of manipulate the
optics of this thing i just i don't like
it here's what i would say if you know
truckers are in a position
where they can make
a huge difference
and the fact that they're willing to
sacrifice and make a difference i i have
a lot of respect and admiration for that
so
i would say at this point if you have
specific goals in mind something that
you want to see happen something you're
pushing for i think a trucker strike
across the country would be much more
effective
because best case scenario with another
convoy
which i think most people are going to
look at that and kind of go on and say
we just saw this
right um the best case scenario is that
you're there and you kind of make you
make a stink for a little bit and and
then but then you're dispersed and you
go home that's like best case scenario
and nothing terrible happens
nothing is really achieved though
i think a strike on the other hand
now you really want to impose your will
in a peaceful way
that's how you do it i would think
all right
let's go to
this uh briefly sarah jones is a writer
for new york magazine and uh she wrote
an article titled
household
tyrants and she wrote in her caption to
the article i wrote about the parental
rights push and its relationship to the
gop's authoritarian view of power
and she says conservatives imagine the
parent as a household tyrant
their rights both supersede and are in
conflict with the rights of the child
key to this is the parent's role as a
local enforcer of the gop's national
agenda
okay a couple of things here
first of all obviously she's not worried
about the rights of the child at all
that is not her concern
her concern is entirely the rights of
the state the right of the government to
interfere in the family
her concern is the right of the of the
the state to come between
the child and the parent that's what she
cares about
just give a damn about the rights of a
child
to begin with if you're pro-abortion
you are in no position to ever talk
about the rights of a child
because in your view a child at a
certain stage in development has
zero rights and zero moral worth has no
is is uh owed no legal protection
whatsoever in your view and now you want
to talk about the rights of a child
so that's the first thing we always have
to establish is that this is a bad faith
argument it's a it's a dishonest
argument she doesn't really care about
the rights of a child
once we've established that we can also
uh note the fact that
well
you know she's scandalized by the idea
that the rights of the parent would come
before the rights of the child
but of course the rights of the parent
supersede the rights of the child
obviously
that's the case um
legally
in that adults have lots of legal rights
that children don't have
it's also it's also the case uh
in each individual family if the family
is properly ordered
in my home
you know my home is not a democracy
you you can't run a family that way
that's a recipe for chaos in your family
and it's chaos that
will hurt the child most of all because
what the child needs is a properly
ordered
family
with with peace and security at home
and stability that's what the kid needs
and you don't achieve that by giving the
child an equal voice in the family
everything you do you put it up for a
vote
and the views and opinions of your
four-year-old uh weigh equally against
your opinions as as an adult and the
person running the family the person who
earns all the money and provides
everything
um
that's that's that's not a recipe for
for anything good for the child
what you're doing there actually is your
setting this is another
another one of the goals of of the left
is they want us they want the state to
come between the parent and the child
but they also want to set each
individual family member against each
other sort of in in competition
and that's that's what you're doing here
when there's not when there isn't a a
sense of proper order
now it's just a constant competition
between
uh the child and the the father and and
and father and mother also in
competition and everybody's sort of
vying for power
in this kind of machiavellian way
but that's not how the
a family is supposed to be run
so in my family uh no my
my kids do not have equal say in in what
happens in the house
far from it
uh they oftentimes depending on what it
is have get no vote at all very often
and my wife and i have the right
to do lots of things that our kids
cannot do
one example uh we can stay up as late as
we want we might we would pay the price
the next day but we can do my kids they
have a bedtime
and sometimes my kids will say to me
that's not fair why do you get to stab
because we're the adults and you're the
child and this is how it works
but along with having those rights it
also means that you have because the the
flip side of the coin of the rights coin
when you flip the coin over you find
responsibilities responsibilities always
come tied with rights when you try to
remove
the responsibility dimension from rights
you get again chaos which is what we're
seeing in our in our country
um
so while we have many rights that the
child that our children don't we also
have many responsibilities that they
don't
which would be basically all of the all
of the serious responsibilities
ultimately fall to us
so that's how a family's supposed to
work but this is also what you get when
you have a lot of childless people
pontificating about the family and how
families are supposed to operate when
they obviously have no experience with
it and no idea let's get down to the
comment section
[Music]
[Music]
sweet baby comments
let's go to clip 8.
computer
what is a woman
as a noun woman can have a few meanings
one
the female human being as distinguished
from a girl or a man
two
an adult female person three
a female attendant to a lady of rank
four
a wife computer
what is a human female
according to wikipedia a woman is an
adult female human
prior to adulthood a female human is
referred to as a girl the plural women
is sometimes used in certain phrases
such as women's rights to denote female
humans regardless of age
typically women have two x chromosomes
and are capable of pregnancy and giving
birth from puberty until menopause
thank you
absolutely happy to help computer
i'm straight
thanks for telling me
computer
i'm gay
thanks for telling me
wow
is it which one is that alexa
that's alexa alexa is a transphobe
that's very disturbing to find out
and and also homophobic
i mean you could you can come out to
alexa
uh which is obviously you know that's
that's the first thing you should do
when you're coming out first to let all
your computer systems know
um update them on the news
and all she says is thanks for telling
me dismissively
very disappointing very disappointed in
alexa okay j star says first matt said
that narcissism was the biggest problem
in our society then he said it was
cowardice that was the biggest problem
so which is it narcissism or cowardice
the answer jay is yes
that's the answer yes
charles says matt i guess you never
learned anything in history class
because there are great examples in
history people like just like vladimir
putin that people like you before world
war ii started
that chose to ignore the problem it's
almost like people like yourself are not
going to be happy unless we do repeat
our history
good luck with that effort by the way
matt war with russia might just happen
if you want it or not
well i agree with your last statement
anyway it might happen whether i want it
or not and i certainly don't
um the only thing i'll say a couple
things charles
first of all
not everything in history is analogous
not everything that happens is analogous
worth world war ii okay
i know that's what we learned on the
internet is that everything that occurs
is just like world war ii
and if you're on
if you stand against the prevailing
opinion about any situation or
occurrence then you are taking the side
of the bad guys in world war ii that's
the lesson from the internet but it's
not a lesson that we should take to
heart because it's not true
but also there's this here's what i'm
trying to figure out charles maybe you
can help me out with this
because i'm being told
and i don't know if you would say this
or not but i i i have heard this bit
about oh it's just like world war ii
putin putin is hitler and if we ignore
it then it's like ignoring hitler in the
early going
so i've heard that a lot
but also the same people saying that
are the ones breathlessly insisting that
oh
they don't want to send any troops they
don't of course they don't support
sending troops in to fight russia
so wait wait a second but which is it
because if this is just like world war
ii
and putin is just like hitler and it's
the same kind of thing then wouldn't you
support sending troops in i assume you
supported sending troops into world war
ii
so
so which is it
on one hand you you are describing this
in a way
that would um seem to justify sending
troops in but then on the other hand
you're claiming that you don't want to
send troops in
this is what i don't understand
and this also makes me uneasy
because you've got one side of this
discussion where it does not seem to me
that they're being honest
what i would predict is that you know
i'd give it two weeks but it might be
more like two days
sometime in the near future all of the
people you could take screenshots of all
the tweets and everything you see people
say ah of course i'm not supporting
setting troops in almost all of them in
short order will be saying oh yeah let's
send the troops in
and if you listen to what they're saying
you you put the denials aside right now
and listen to everything else they're
saying especially these world war ii and
hitler comparisons uh it's it's obvious
already that that's basically what
they're calling for without saying it
and maybe they don't want to say it yet
because they know that
um it's just
the ground has not been prepared for it
quite yet
so they want to prepare the ground and
then they'll start sprinkling the seeds
of
of you know actually getting involved in
world war three
but
i am um
i'm gonna stay consistent on this you
know
i to get troops involved in this
conflict for ukraine would be it would
be disastrous for us on
a scale that you
i don't even think we can imagine how
bad it could get for us to do that
but i i am sitting here anticipating i
know it's going to happen soon enough
mark my words
soon enough you're going to start
hearing
these people explicitly saying let's
send the troops in
um and finally anthony says hey matt
what's your favorite liam neeson murder
slash revenge movie uh i love them all
because because they're all like like
exactly the same
and it's pretty much the same story over
and over again
and uh it's it's always a family member
that's you know either been kidnapped
and has to be rescued or they've already
been killed and now it's a revenge thing
and so it's kind of like comfort food
it's it's why i like old-fashioned
westerns and why i don't like a lot of
the new westerns because in the old
westerns it's it's basically there's
there's like three basic western stories
and then you just get different versions
of the same story
and that's the appeal that's the charm
and so same thing with liam neeson but
what's the best one i don't think
there's any argument it's obviously
going to be original taken which i think
is
not only the best liam neeson movie but
probably one of the best action movies
in the last 30 years america supported
ukraine's move to hand over its nukes in
1994 under a promise for russia not to
evade and look what happened it seems
that we're not to be trusted either
that's why it's more important than ever
to understand just how insidious these
foreign threats are within our own
country and we have just the way for you
to do it our new show the enemy within
is a docu-series featuring acclaimed
journalist and expert in national
threats lee smith
smith uncovers a political coup
orchestrated by america's ruling class
to generate their own wealth and power
in exchange for the slow rise of china's
communist party in america at the
expense of the american people's safety
and freedom in the third episode leon
covers the infiltration of america's
universities by chinese spies
students affiliated with the ccp and
american professors who've sold their
allegiance to the chinese communist
party for bribes you can see a little
bit of that in the trailer here
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that match the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and
[Music]
had a executioners
spy as her driver for 20 years we're not
talking about one person infiltrating
senior levels at the cia or the white
house we're talking about an entire
elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
all episodes of the enemy within are
streaming now exclusively at the daily
wire so if you're not a member now's the
time to change it head to dailywire.com
subscribe
to join us today and while you're there
if you if you ever wanted to be a fly on
the wall for conversations that don't
take place on screen uh now's your
chance and ben shapiro's new show the
search you'll join him and his closest
friends as they head to ben's favorite
local spots to dive into some deep
conversations that you often don't get
to hear when the camera uh when the
camera's rolling his his first guest was
the great jordan peterson and the second
episode of the search will feature his
other very good friend highly lauded
historian niall ferguson it's an
excellent conversation and i highly
recommend you check it out the episode
releases tonight thursday 24th will be
exclusive to daily wire members so if
you're not currently a member head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
and finally as the beloved author of the
best-selling children's lgbtq plus book
johnny the walrus uh as you know i'm an
important voice in the transgender
conversation in the in the lgbt
conversation broadly that's why i was
invited to dr phil to discuss these
important issues as a noted expert
the other experts on the panel you know
apparently we're not experts i couldn't
even answer what a woman was you could
check out that out if you haven't seen
those clips yet even more importantly if
you haven't picked up a copy of my
best-selling children's book you should
do so immediately it's sold out in 48
hours when it was released but don't
worry more copies are on the way you can
reserve johnny the walrus now on amazon
or go to johnnywalrus.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know we're quite used to hearing
insane things from the body positivity
camp but yesterday a body positivity
activist and fat acceptance activist
named monica crete
upped the ante considerably
on her social media accounts which have
all now been set to private crete calls
herself a writer consultant educator
fighting weight stigma in public health
and medicine
she also hosts seminars on the topic of
being fat unfortunately you missed the
most recent one hosted alongside
activist mikey mercedes who is a woman
by the way although i didn't have to
tell you that she's a woman because the
body positivity people are always women
can you remember the last time you saw a
man's fatness celebrated
when's the last time one of these body
positivity fat people was a man it like
never happens
because you're still allowed to fat
shame men it's specifically women who
have the right to balloon to whatever
size they please without any criticism
from anybody so anyway the seminar was
titled fat phobia in public health
and was specifically meant for weight
inclusive dietitians
of course the term weight inclusive
dietitian is a bit like the term
cancer-inclusive oncologist or
cockroach-inclusive pest control
you can't include that is support and
celebrate
the very thing your job requires you to
treat
and destroy
so there are many such contradictions uh
in the world of the body positivity
activists many absurdities and they all
culminate in this tweet for monica she
wrote quote
periodic reminder that treating and
preventing obesity actually means trying
to conversion therapy fat people into
becoming thin people despite zero
evidence that this is remotely possible
you heard that right
monica the consultant and educator says
that dieting is a form of conversion
therapy
and moreover that there is zero evidence
that dieting actually makes anyone
skinnier
monica believes or wants you to believe
anyway that caloric intake actually has
nothing at all to do with weight
what about all the millions of people
who have managed to drop weight by
limiting calories well they're all
mythological they don't exist
if you're one of those people you don't
exist i'm sorry to say or else you're
part of a grand fat phobic conspiracy
a conspiracy which which includes almost
every doctor and nutritionist in the
world by the way
and what about the fact that starving
people always tend to be very skinny
so it's a coincidence
and the fact that obesity is only common
in western countries where people eat a
lot of food and hardly move
what about the almost complete absence
of obesity in the third world for that
matter what about the fact that our
skeletons and internal organs literally
were not made to carry the kind of
weight that monica and her fellow fat
activists are forcing their skeletons
and organs to carry
that's why fat people die young
that's why there are no morbidly obese
85 year olds
your your body at that age just can't
can't
handle it can't con it can't carry all
that weight around anymore
what about that
don't all of these facts point
incontrovertibly to the notion that you
get fat when you eat a lot and get
skinny when you eat less
no says monica
don't ask her to explain herself either
it makes her feel good to see the world
the way she sees it and your job is to
enforce whatever perception of the world
and herself makes her feel good
that's your sacred responsibility
because she says so
now as crazy as all this is
the most revealing aspect is the way
that she uses the term fat people and
skinny people
now she doesn't mean fat and skinny as a
mere description of a transient physical
trait
what she said when she says fat people
she does not mean people who happen to
have an unhealthy amount of lard on
their bodies
now for her fat is an immutable and
defining characteristic it's an identity
it's who she is deep inside it's her
very soul is fat
fatness is an identity
i tell you we're only months away since
i'm making predictions today on the show
i can also tell you this we're only
months away from somebody coming up with
a special pronouns for fat people
which will give a whole new meaning to
the term trans fat
and i'm not joking about the pronouns in
our culture the special pronoun it's how
you affirm and consecrate an identity
it's like a baptism
and the good thing is that the blessed
pronouns though they are supposed to
have this mystical significance can
change any time
so just for fun let's look at another
example of this phenomenon dipping into
the tick tock well with the help of our
friend libs of ticket tick tock who
found this one um here's a woman
announcing her new pronouns listen to
this
hey guys i think it's finally time for
an update on my gender series i'm not
gonna lie i have no idea what part this
is but
let's go
okay first off um i am now just going by
k now um i no longer like to be called
kayla um unless it's
for work and just because it's kind of
confusing with the paperwork and stuff
so yeah
i also am now using all pronouns instead
of none
um
i don't regret not going by any pronouns
before but
i do feel that
i
it just makes i don't know it just
that's what's happening
another thing though i am still
xenogender um i still
that is still my gender that i identify
with and i am still bisexual so those
things have not changed at all
so yeah this is just a little quick
update um that i have for y'all and
i don't know i just let me know if you
have any questions um i'd love to answer
them
okay make sure to update your scoreboard
uh now uh
kayla is now k
she's still zeno gender or whatever that
is but um
she went from no pronouns to all
pronouns
that's that's that's the update now how
could she have had no pronouns before
did she not exist was she some kind of
phantom or something
and how can she go by all pronouns now
what does she really mean all pronouns
even like it
can i call her an it
i suppose so
she is a man a woman a thing a nothing
and everything
she is all things and nothing she
transcends time and space she's like
some sort of pantheistic deity
and you better not so much as suggest
otherwise because your job again is to
affirm as we've learned to do anything
less than a firm to express even mild
disagreement with a person's
self-perception is to engage in
conversion therapy and conversion
therapy is the ultimate sin because it's
an attack on a person's self-identity
which is to say that it's an attack on
their entire world on their reality
because they recognize no world or
reality aside from the one they've
created in their heads
now
i want to get a little bit more
philosophical here
so let's bring together fat acceptance
stuff
pronouns
uh hysteria about conversion therapy and
all the rest of it
what's what's really going on
i think what's happening is that is that
we are conscious beings to begin with
um we are aware of ourselves
aware of our own fragility and
impermanence
and as far as we know we're the only
creatures in the universe cursed with
such an awareness
so we find ourselves floating in this
vast ocean of existence wondering about
the reason and the purpose for it all
we came from non-existence
and will fade back into the abyss
from which we came at least physically
and we know all of that
the only way to survive is to reach out
for an anchor point you know something
stable
try to find an island to rest on
because we can't be conscious beings
floating along with no purpose and yet
aware of it the whole time we can't do
that indefinitely there's just no way to
live you can't live that way
people who try to live that way end up
not living for very long
the problem that we face in the west is
that
we had an anchor
we had an island but we abandoned it
we gave up on god on religion which was
our source of identity our sense of
purpose our solid ground
we decided that it wasn't good enough
for us so we jumped back into the sea
with no real idea of where else to go
instead
so now we're adrift aimless and
meandering and totally susceptible to
any storm that comes along we have no
shelter from it no escape from the
crashing waves what we're witnessing
with the proliferation of gender
identities the pronoun madness the fat
accepts and stuff are a bunch of
drowning adrift people
reaching out for anchors for little
islands for some kind of stability and
identity
having traded in the one true source of
stability and identity available to us
but these anchors aren't really anchors
because they're not anchored in anything
they don't go all the way down to the
sea floor
the islands are just driftwood at best
they don't provide the sense of purpose
and belonging and worth that these
people want from them which is why
they're always trading them out for
something else
but really they're still lost in the sea
hopeless and alone
so i guess it's a good thing that fat
people are more buoyant on second
thought
i had a good philosophical thing going
there i had i ruined it with a fat joke
i should have done that but i did in any
case the point is monica crete the fat
acceptance activist
is today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
wadowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2022.
putin launches a full-scale invasion of
ukraine a texas middle school teacher
says conservative christians should die
of covid and the u.s immigrant
population reaches an all-time high
check it out on the michael knoll show